that isn't something that i ever learned
because i was interested in the
technical but i was interested in like
well why why am i not getting the
smoothness of a color transition
how long did it take you to fully grasp
all the camera settings
i
you know there are a lot of cameras that
i couldn't run but actually most cameras
i couldn't run by myself at this point i
don't i am uh
i am
i'm very reliant on my
camera team for sure
i am always familiar with how different
camera centers react to light and color
skin tones the noise floors like i i pay
attention to the sensor and the
reactivity uh but often
i am not familiar with building out a
full camera with its wireless follow i
could i couldn't put together a wireless
follow focus and my camera team i'm so
rely i'm reliant on them for a number of
things
but for sure they like my first ac
bryant i've been working with him for
years i'm reliant on him for putting
together our camera even when we're
ordering equipment
i do broad strokes i'm like i want these
lenses these filters
i prefer this monitor
but in terms of the
cables and all the little the follow
focus are wireless like i
i have some
leanings but really i leave that to him
and it becomes it's a big your camera
team ends up becoming a huge part of
your whole process and i'm for sure that
way and letting go of some of the
technical
uh elements was tricky for me because i
felt like well wait a minute i'm the
cinematographer i'm supposed to know
everything and i was like oh no no no i
need to know how the image will end up
how we get there and the gear that's on
the camera
if some of it matters to me because i
have you know if i know it's handheld
i'm going to have different needs as
opposed to if i know i'm going to be on
dolly and all that but
yeah in terms of the
you know the settings or switching
things over to you know i mean now the
alexa mini have been shooting with that
camera predominantly for the last few
years i'm very familiar with that
um just because of the number of times
but
you know if i were shooting on let's say
a sony venice or or a red it's been a
while since i've shot on a red uh
i would probably need help changing the
color temperature or the iso or frame
rate or all that and i i have no problem
asking for help with that stuff i don't
i don't feel like that's part of my job
description i need to understand it i
need to understand where what i'm
looking to get out of it but getting
there i'm content to let my acs help
guide me
what technical part of the craft took
you the longest to learn yeah the
technical the
cinematography really is technical and
actually i there's a feature that i may
be shooting you know who knows now but
uh that we might shoot on film
and i am excited but also very nervous
about it because i have i was trained up
on film
but
to
light
boldly or dramatically for film is much
scarier than for digital because
with all our cameras now we have a
monitor and you can see what the image
is going to look like right now on film
you can't do that you have your light
meter out and you're talking about like
contrast ratios and how much light is
here versus here and where you can
you know i'm now used to i light off of
my monitor i almost never i bring a
light meter to set i almost never touch
it i'm really using the monitor and
to go back to film
scares me a little bit because i want to
make sure i can still be bold with my
choices
but i have to make sure that it's not
too contrasty or
too you know too flat like i don't it's
really so i think
it's funny
in a way
the thing that now intimidates me or
makes me nervous on the technical side
is the thing that i learned first and
we've just because of technology have
gotten away from that
and now to go back to it and like oh i
don't have the safety of knowing what my
image is going to look like
right away you're kind of you have to go
back to
your own faith and understanding the
latitude of a film stock and contrast
ratios how it reacts to color
so i think that's the thing that right
now probably makes me the most nervous
on a on a technical level but
you know there are
i think there's also you know there's
there's all kinds of things like how to
bit rates and
you know
uh uh like a lot of our dslrs
for their color it's like 422
and i'm used to shooting 4-4-4 on an
alexa mini and for a long time i had no
concept of what that is and now i
understand oh this is like the way it
captures color and why that's important
to me is because it allows for gradation
between like
different like blues in a sky like it
starts usually by the horizon it's a
little gray gets a little bluer and then
deeper blue as you go up and different
camera sensors can't handle that because
of the way they capture color
so
i didn't
it
that isn't something that i ever learned
because i was interested in the
technical but i was interested in like
well why why am i not getting the
smoothness of a color transition
so
that stuff has come to me kind of just
by
shooting it's not like i sat and was
studying books and
got it that way it's just kind of
learning because of really broken images
and how do i not break this image next
time that kind of thing
were you one of these kids that used to
take things apart to see how they worked
uh you know i i was always curious so i
would take things apart but not to see
how they worked i would take things
apart because i was just like i wonder
what the inside of this looks like
sounds like a serial killer
but yeah no i i actually
i would not call myself a technical
cinematographer now i that might not be
true i may actually be and i realize
sometimes like oh i know more stuff than
i thought
but i never
the leader of it is always like how does
this image feel like i look at when new
cameras get announced i will look at the
specs
but what i've learned is that like
listing the specs on paper kind of don't
matter to me now they give me a baseline
they help me understand frame rates how
will it do in low light what is its
native iso like there are technical
things that i now am very familiar with
and i understand what that means but
really i need to look at footage because
the way that they capture motion the way
that they capture skin tones the way
that they like the highlights the way
they blow out
like those are so my
my
technical the technical information of
cameras has always been secondary to the
my aesthetic reaction to it my emotional
reaction to the image for sure
yeah i think you probably do know a lot
more than you think but that maybe goes
along with the humility so well i also
think it's just years of doing it like
some of it just has has come because
i've i haven't understood why something
is a certain way and so it's out of
necessity but
yeah i would say out of necessity like
i'm just like what is it what is this
and so i've
but i've really i've been in it for so
long
so it's yeah i think that knowledge has
just
come almost through osmosis just through
wading through it for so long